[Musique]
rapid et dans les angles tranchant
je suis très excité au large des pistes
ans comme ce soir c'est au tour du thème
de pinces et de l'engagement en fait
c'est l'engagement pur et dur c'est
reprendre des chansons
qui nous parlent une conque qui
pourraient raconter des choses sur nous
je fais les barbares de lavilliers
j'avais jamais entendu ce morceau je les
écoute et je suis dit ok on m'a dit ah
ça se tirait bien j'ai dit ok d'accord
vas-y jeu par là dedans ça va être mon
amour importe
[Applaudissements]
en fait à force de le répéter à force
d'essayer des choses à force d'en parler
avec les musiciens aussi qui nous
accompagnent j'ai découvert vraiment ce
que c'est que ce texte voulait dire pour
l'auteur ce qui voulait dire pour moi et
ce qui mettait en avant et en fait c'est
bingo c'est vraiment exactement là d'où
je viens de besançon d'une petite ville
où il se passe pas grand chose ou ses
treize ouvriers etc c'est aussi mon
histoire c'est aussi ma famille c'est ça
que je raconte dedans lui bernard
lavilliers parle de saint-etienne moi je
parle de besançon c'est la même chose
donc au final j'ai grave découvrir
quelque chose sur moi en faisant ça et
ça tu sais trop bien namouh remporte
mois
emportez mois loi de la dot
vers des faits chagrin vers des pays
fassent
[Musique]
dossier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya presque un stimuli extrême d'être
trouvé avec autant de gens parce que tu
as plus l'habitude mais ça fait tout ça
fait du bien et et c'est cool c'est beau
parce que franchement tout le monde a
fait du jeu vraiment un travail assez
remarquable au nombre au salon de l'auto
hygro américain milliers le nouveau
botté des chefs de jours qu'ils ne
pourront jamais ses pieds ouais bah si
c'est vraiment ils jouent ce jeu ils ont
dit oui et il a su me ruine j'ai du mal
à aimer à trouver mes mots et le sommeil
s'en rende compte mais je suis animé
énormément abîmé probablement portée des
gens beaux mais de voir des gens qui
sont aussi entier dans cet engagement là
et dans leur propre vie dans six raconté
dans ce qui est véhicule pour ça
exceptionnel cette sincérité la
référence
[Musique]
charbel monde en france
percée de temps insouciante
[Musique]
engagements les plus real et
l'engagement parfois quand on pense à
l'engagement penser à la coller on pense
à la révolte mais l'engagement ça peut
être s'engager avec soi même à être une
meilleure personne chaque jour ça peut
être s'engager dans la gratitude ça peut
donc pour moi c'est important d'incarner
ce pont aussi de l'engagement je
trouvais intéressant aussi l'avoir
d'avoir ce soir parce que en fait il ya
d'autres artistes ont choisi des choses
un peu plus un peu plus énervé et le
contraste est intéressant
[Musique]
je t'aime
tu sais ma france à moi elle a des
chambres où elle s'enferme l'aideront
jamel debbouze à l'humour est peut-être
son frère
on veut pas les murs et les trois parce
qu'ils sont trop terme elle se plaît à
la merde comment la pousse à ne
rien faire
le fait que des festivals porte des
gestes d'engagement comme ça surtout
dans une année comme celle ci où je
pense qu'on a besoin à nouveau que les
artistes travaillent le collectif
havrais ensemble qu'on fasse front avec
le plus vivienne et des coups que lui
soit délivré des messages comme ça de
revendication doit dire et de poésie
[Musique]
600 noire s'échappe
sur les
[Musique]
sinon
ben ali
liberté mangez-vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]